Hey Rachel, how's it going? Oh, hi sir.
Do you mind if I can ask you
67 questions there? Cool.
Do you miss your undergraduate
years at Swarthmore? Yes.
You got a phd in math from two. How was
that experience? It was pretty miserable.
What is something you miss
about where you grew up? Um,
my friends and family and delicious food.
You need a PT to do machine
learning research? Absolutely not.
What excites you the most
about machine learning?
I just think all the real world problems
that can solve. It's really powerful.
What was it like working
at the early days? It was,
it was pretty chaotic. What was the
funniest part about working at Uber?
I think it was,
it was a once in a lifetime opportunity
and it was a really interesting data set
to have all the gps data.
What website do you absolutely
love to spend time on?
I guess Twitter.
I love hate.
What country do you believe
will contribute the most
to ml and the next decade?
Oh, that's a good question.
Um, I think a lot of countries,
well theory till what time do you wake up?
I usually around 8:00 AM
paper machine,
morning paper of 2018 and I
think Leslie Smith's one cycle.
I like Tim. Nick got Bruce data sheets
for datasets. You can be one person.
Who would it be at the sane up to faculty.
What do you do to relax?
Like Yoga and playing with my daughter.
What's it like three research and as
a full time job it's a lot of fun.
I really enjoy kind of like the
creativity and flexibility. I have
words we're trying to make deep learning,
easier to use for people that don't,
can't afford expensive computers.
It might not have giant data,
sad center kind of all around the
world and from different backgrounds.
What's your working dynamic life?
I was really great.
We're just kind of totally on the same
page and have very similar values.
Um,
I'm really proud of our courses and just
our students' successes and kind of all
that companies they've launched
in the projects they've,
they've completed or done and I think a
finish finishing my phd and then in the
face of kind of a lot of
uncertainty and obstacles.
Why are there so few
women in machine learning?
This is a big question.
I think there's a lot of um,
there's some toxicity in the field and
a lot of related fields of math and
computer science.
What is one thing that scares me?
I think our current political situation,
we were moving at Clu us now I don't
my daughter
a yoga and playing with my daughter.
What is something surprising about,
um, like I said, I grew up in Texas.
You prefer cats or dogs?
Dogs.
What's the machine learning model
that doesn't take it up? Attention.
Random forest.
That's my like computational linear
Algebra class was a lot of fun.
If you keep one experience again,
what would it be?
The month I spent in Japan.
Why do you think deep learning has gotten
so it's really, it's really useful.
What is your favorite operating system?
I don't have a strong preference.
Most adventurous thing you've ever done.
It said switching into tech
and moving to San Francisco,
getting rid of everything I owned
when I didn't know anybody out here.
One resource you use to stay
up to date in machine learning?
Twitter programming, language of
choice for machine learning. Python.
Favorite professor at j?
Tell Baka and Cheryl grood from
Swarthmore. It's math department.
Why do you think programming is fun?
It's really fun to create things. It's
neat to have the power to build stuff.
What's the most amazing
thing in the world?
That's a huge question.
I think friendship and family favorite.
Comfort food,
comfort food,
maybe ginger,
chicken and rice.
What was your first program?
The first program that I remember was
we had to output how much interest you
would pay on a credit card.
Just like I'll put it to the terminal.
You got an all expenses paid
trip to one country where you go,
I'd like to go to Malaysia.
Would you live on Mars?
I'm not sure I would visit.
What is one thing you can't live without?
Um, uh, high quality pillow.
What is one skill you wish you
had better negotiation skills.
What text editor do you use them?
What open source library.
Do you really like?
Pi Torch and the fast I library was
a hard problem. You recently saw
dealing with brain surgery.
What's the meaning of life,
I think to, to love the people around
you and to try to have a positive impact.
What is one piece of advice you'd give
yourself 10 years ago? Um, it's okay.
It's okay to be happy now.
You spend more time on the
internet or real life? Nike,
be close. Maybe real life.
What's something you've
learned in the past month?
MMM.
Yeah.
I've been learning a lot more about a
ethical issues and kind of disinformation
and propaganda. You like spicy food? Yes.
What is a movie that made you cry?
Big Hero six.
If you ran the world,
what is one law you that universal
health care is the singularity near now.
Who is one person you looked
up to when you were in college?
I looked up to David. Eddie
has a health care, um,
for evidence based healthcare proponent.
If you were to start from scratch today,
what is the learning resource you
would use to learn machine learning?
I may be biased, but a fast AI,
practical, deep learning for coders.
What is one goal you have
in the next 10 years?
I think really to kind of
continue doing what I'm doing.
Favorite subject in school,
when you were growing up, math,
if you could be a superhero,
who would it be?
Penny from inspector gadget.
What's your spirit animal?
Maybe a squirrel. What do you predict
comes next after the deep learning hype,
and I think the deep learning is
going to keep going for a while.
We still have so much potential
to unlock their. Cool. Rachel,
thanks so much for answering
these questions. Oh, thank
you. Who else you around.